is that the spiciest thing you've ever
eaten oh
yeah that's not nice why are you doing
this to
[Music]
me hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Lou theu he's a
baft award-winning documentarian and
journalist who for decades has immersed
himself in some of the most dangerous
complicated and controversial aspects of
The Human Experience in this he has a
series of six interviews with well-known
personalities coming to the BBC Lou THU
welcome to the show thank you for having
me how are you around spicy food before
we get started I'd like to think I'm
pretty good uh but that feels like I'm
setting myself up to fail if I say that
so I want to play things down and say
average
here we
[Music]
go
nice if I was eating purely for pleasure
that's pretty good I'm actually now I'm
thinking about it I'm like I probably
say that's fine I wouldn't want to go
much over that
and yet here we
are so one of the unique things about
your upcoming interview series is that
you're meeting your guests where they
are in their life you know having a sit
down conversation with champion boxer
Anthony Joshua immediately following a
fight yeah as someone with a studio show
I'm curious what do you think is gained
by setting the interviews and the
natural habitat of your guests okay good
question I think um you know my
background is documentary Making and um
I started out working for documentary
filmmaker called Michael Moore and he
famously made a a movie called Roger and
me and he came out of a ver film making
tradition where you sort of fly on the
wall right and you just sort of observe
people in their natural habitat almost a
little bit like an anthropologist would
like studying a tribe or something and
you just see people when they're not on
right they're not performing and the
idea is that as the days go by you see a
more natural presentation you see
someone uh coming across as themselves
as opposed to sort of a curated version
there's both the the behind the scenes
component of you know Anthony Joshua in
the dressing room but there's also a
master interview component where you
sort of see them in a more composed
setting the garlic I like there's
something reassuring about the
color but you seem to be into it you
must like the sauce fine I'm hungry I
know me too
I like it without thinking about it too
hard is there a lifestyle or belief
system outside of your own that you
found yourself being most woed by when
you spent so much time in the belly of
it okay
um I don't know why but my mind went to
polyamory yeah you know what that is
right yeah yeah you had the whipped
cream like rubbed all
over yeah consensual non-
monogamy I I I you know I felt like I
get it like when you start to analyze
it uh in certain respects monogamy seems
weirder you know especially if we live
as we now you know we live hopefully to
be 90 plus years old right all being
well and now they're talking about maybe
being I don't know if you're following
these Tech Bros who are saying we're
going to live to be 300 can you imagine
being married to the same person for
like 280
years um it feels like it would start
you'd start craving something else on
the menu figuratively speaking so it all
made sense to you so there was so I sort
of thought yeah that that I except for
the sexual jealousy part which I think
would make my head
[Music]
explode tasty that's the best you got
come on I'll remember you said that I
like Thai food mhm and a jungle Curry
that they do at a restaurant in Los
Angeles it became a a ritual for a while
once a
year and then the third year I was like
why are we doing this to ourselves right
you know what I mean like being married
for 110 years or something you know yeah
a very great B lasted but we got to go
our separate ways so I've heard you
discuss the influence of being a dual
citizen of Britain the US and the impact
that it's had on your work what
superpowers do you think that grants you
working on either side of the pond I
think we're not seeing it threatening
you know when I arrive I could go up to
Idaho in fact I have gone up to Idaho
Mountain Mike to meet a militia man who
sort of thinks that the federal
government is going to is satanic and is
going to come and invade and take his
guns away and and he's like uh well
hello there you know well so you've come
all the way from across the pond you
know and it's sort of this friendly like
I've arrived like a kind of visit
visiting dignitary you know this sort of
imposing forbidding figure is softened
towards me that makes sense to me it's
beautiful Los
centes this says first we Feast on it
which suggests it might be one of your
ones yeah story checks out Yeah we
actually do make this one but you know
what Lou if you don't like it you can
let me know it's disgusting yeah it's
okay it tastes very nice mhm a little
bit hotter than the last one but not
overwhelming for you yeah what do you
think pretty good right very good I save
very
good it's like me reviewing one of my
own programs yeah right exactly 10 out
of
10 I like the skinny guy with the
glasses I want to see more of
him from where you sit I'm curious
what's your take on the current
landscape of documentaries because on
one hand there seem to be more made now
than ever before but there is this sort
of palpable shift towards you know true
crime documentaries or documentaries
about celebrities that are produced and
commissioned by the celebrity mhm
ethically it's more complicated because
in some cases you have big stars
executing their own programs um or you
know producing them with their own
production companies you have payoffs or
pay payments to dubious characters but
the thing is is if I'm enjoying what I'm
watching I'm a happy man yeah what does
it matter you know what I mean mhm and I
I get that where does it all lead and I
think all those conversations need to be
had like you know like if you don't want
to be incentivizing a criminal to do
crime so that they can
then I just kill one more person I'll
get my Netflix deal that was in bad
taste wasn't it no no nothing anything
goes on this show you blame it on the
wings Blame It On the Wings Lou it's
they're creeping up a bit on me you know
what I mean I'm getting an after blast
there's a cumulative effect too going
here yeah there's a it's a sort of a low
drone of um Tong tongue tongue
activity warmth growing but so of the
recent stream kind of ones like wild
wild country the Jinx last dance this
new Beckham one yeah Tinder swindler
yeah those are all kind of bangers
they're all kind of awesome and you're
like give me more Cliffhanger rack it up
next one you know what I mean that makes
sense to me Lou are you ready to move on
to the halfway point yeah I might need a
little sip of what did you suggest like
the milk yeah I think the milk is
probably the best for you I'm not like
you know I'm not having trouble
didn't it sound like I'm in trouble I'm
not just need
[Music]
a excuse me you can't always tell right
off the bat can you don't overthink
you're going back in in that you it is
hot but you're you feel good about it
thought I I thought I was supposed to
have more than one bite no no I respect
it I'm going right with you yeah it's
quite
hot that is quite hot mhm
yeah yeah they're not lying can feel it
on my lips yeah the show is like really
St that's only not even halfway it is
halfway you are exactly halfway
well five and five yeah we are now at at
the exact halfway point and you're doing
great you're doing
great is someone who clearly sees the
value in talking to subjects with
viewpoints that are different than your
own what's your take on the growing
backlash against platforming certain
ideas or people oh my God I have to I I
don't an intelligent and kind of complex
question while having my that's the show
the show yeah that's the
show uh good
question oh jeez um platforming is uh
something that you should be aware of
and um here's the thing there's a
difference between giving someone a
platform I a megaphone you know is is an
audience 10 million people
have at it say what you like and on
that's on one hand and on the other hand
you asking questions you you are attempt
to impose a shape to what what takes
place you know the good journalism is
not necessarily like a platform and and
and I think by the way like that is that
is a I made a joke about but that's a
good question and um something that I
need to be conscious of like over the
years I've made programs
about neo-nazis um relig Cults you know
to a great extent I think due to the
internet and social media lone actors
like people who would have been like
Fringe voices guys who would have been
out in a log cabin somewhere in in a
wood somewhere um maybe kind of like
writing little newsletters you know and
and and sending them out in brown paper
bags now those guys have um or maybe
shortwave radio but now those people
have uh social media accounts and and
they have real uh they have real reach
but I think that doesn't
mean don't don't so they have power but
I don't think that means don't don't
speak to them I think it
means speak it's in a way it's all the
more important to speak to them but um
with a sort of sense of intelligence and
accountability is a ghost is it a
reference to a ghost pepper it is
actually how how far in are you going on
this one I'm going as far as you
go my my mouth is so scorched from the
previous one it's hard to tell is it
just keeping the vibe going or you know
what I
mean yeah I think this one has kind of a
complicated flavor profile you know
where I kind of catch that whiskey and
then it leaves behind that ghost pepper
Trail like right now my throat's pretty
scratchy yeah I we're definitely up
above the tree line I'm continuing the
the mountaineering metaphor and we're
heading into the what's the called the
death zone yeah that's right marching
right into the death zone here we're
going into the death zone I know I know
but together we got this we got this L I
got a little on my yeah back of the
throat good I I might leave that one
there perfect nice is someone who's made
documentaries for decades do you find
that it's easier to get subjects to
comply in this social media age where
everything is always about such
self-promotion uh I do but I don't know
if it's for the reason the reason that
you're suggesting I mean I think excuse
me little bit ghost pepper coming up
here we go I think um what's happened is
I have more visibility now and also
people in general have less anonymity
and so anyone I approach can quite
easily sort of Google me search me up
look at my socials and in general sorry
nose slightly that's the show that's it
okay excuse me sorry for that
oh at the risk of kind of bigging myself
up I'm an award-winning I think you
mentioned in your intro that I have
three bafs I try not to make too much in
[Music]
that so far nothing too troubling right
so this one I think is kind of a chill
number seven we go out with the old and
with the new time it's kind of like an
album like track Seven's an instrumental
yeah yeah right right you don't want to
overlook it too to much cuz it does have
kind of some late life to it oh yeah but
it's a good Jam it's just um it's just
not a single you know yeah yeah yeah I'm
with you on that from undergoing lipo
suction surgery to stripping down in
your underwear to have whipped cream
spread all over you at the uh
polyamorous sensual dinner what do you
think's the most you've ever suffered
for your art thank you for actually
watching some programs or someone watch
something I like your work I like I'm a
fan of your work Lou thank you man um
in terms of suffering there's different
kinds of suffering uh there's acute
embarrassment I've had that a few times
once stripping off for a porn uh for to
get basically on the books of a porn
agent it was called Jim South this was
in the late '90s you had you had the
black couch audition yeah I basically it
wasn't really a casting couch it was
more of a stand naked and just wiggle it
around you were supposed to have wood
for the um for the it wasn't you know in
order like they basic they had these
books of of male
talent in which the male Talent is
standing there and really to be fully
true to life you should be in a state of
arousal right because the director who
comes in to book the talent the male
Talent wants to see what kind of wood
you're working with naturally but I'm
like that's you know I have limits it's
a bridge too far it is a bridge too far
so I'm like I I think it'd be kind of
funny to see me naked having my PO
Polaroid taken for the porn agent I'm
not going to uh get the wood they can
basically go with the the the uh the non
try to find them sa just the the natural
the Natural State Natural State the wood
is in its natural state but it was like
yeah so like moments like that yeah
right part of the job I guess that is
that is when you put yourself in these
worlds you know
yeah and you know what speaking of maybe
not being safe putting yourself in a
world here you are in my world yes and
next sauce is the bomb Beyond
Insanity okay they clue may be in the
name Beyond
Insanity yeah yeah they they kind of
give it away okay
here
cheers ready Down the
[Music]
Hatch something's happening oh wow is
that the spiciest thing you've ever
eaten oh
yeah that's not nice why are you doing
this to
me just it has to be this
way do are these do we have to be nice
about the sauce I don't even don't you
can say whatever want I don't even like
the flavor no it's awful you can say
whatever you want it just tastes like uh
poison it has like a metal taste to it
almost oh that's not nice oh that's bad
yeah it's building I'm in trouble right
and there's more milk we do have some
extra milk here for you and the key here
is there is like a a tight walk where
you don't want to drink too much milk
really yeah yeah yeah oh does this
help I think what you're finding is that
nothing actually helps you know like
once you're in this thing there's
nothing that truly saves you you
know is is it like um you know oh I'm
crying is it like uh
oh it's
just oh
it's that thing where it just keeps
going up yeah and you just got to it's
just getting worse and worse yeah and
when I thought you said like oh it gets
you from I was like it's not too
bad but remember early on when you were
like very that's all you got you know
like uh it's happened to that gu I know
I know this it's an ego death every time
on this show my tongue
feels like a stranger you're right yeah
for an object in there yeah uh it's like
it's glowing it's like it's playing
music but it's you know what I think
it's getting stronger all right stepping
out of this studio stronger Lou pain is
weakness leaving the body body right I
played you know High School football in
America you get you picked up on all
those is that one of the things I saw
that once for like a bodybuilding
convention and I was like I like that
what if anything did the explosion of
your my money don't jiggle jiggle track
what did it teach you if anything thing
about virality on the
internet um almost nothing yeah right
because I I didn't understand it then
and I still don't really understand it I
just know that um one
minute I had uh just you know done an
interview with Amelia de molenberg was a
rep written with a couple of guys in
Jackson Mississippi for an episode of
Weird Weekends the rap's pretty good I
think as a sort of novelty rap but it
still doesn't really really explain why
it caught on and and and naturally as
much of as I've said oh wow it's just a
brilliant thing and it was once in a
lifetime there's a little voice saying
hey do it again you know what about a
Christmas hit like my my sleigh bells
don't jingle jingle do you know what I
mean like I can hear it now and and and
what you know what would be wrong with
that it would make me I'd be I'd have
that beautiful relevance all over again
and then
Good Sense prevails and I'm like don't
be that guy my wife said early on don't
touch it don't chase it let it be good
advice so uh I've by and large done that
other than re-recording a remix and
doing a video and promoting
[Laughter]
it I took a big a bite I saw that did
you I'll join
you
like
like I might have been shot you know
that they say when you're bit by a shark
you know what it feels like you don't
maybe you don't feel it at first right a
tug it's a tug apparently did you know
and it's taking your leg off and then
you look down and like that's weird
there's blood in the
water and then it's that weird I'm going
in circles yeah and there's a shark with
a leg you start to connect the dots and
then maybe you get some
pain and after that I think it gets
worse yeah do you get my metaphor I
think I know what happened I'm immune
because of that cuz that one because
pain was weakness leaving the body and
you entered this next sauce a stronger
Louis that's what happened I did I had
to die in order to be reborn yeah that's
exactly what happened did they say that
in high school football no but that
would be awesome if a Coach did if he
went like that
deep do you have a Mount Rushmore of
documentaries four films off the top of
your head without overthinking it that
you think are like the best foundational
examples of technical excellence in the
genre uh I would go uh Thin Blue Lon
Errol Morris's would be would be in
there I think non-fiction storytelling
very pure it was one of the films that
got me interested in documentary Making
i' I'd probably have to shout out Roger
and me because Michael Moore was
something of a mentor to me and as a
first person piece of Storytelling and
using humor and taking a social issue in
a quirky way oh you know exit through
the gift shop it's bank's film and I
just thought it was
um he's kind of in it but not in it and
it's about street art it's about
self-promotion it's a great watch and
then the last one I would say maybe is
the act of killing which is by Joshua
Oppenheimer and a very heavy subject a
set of atrocities in Indonesia in which
thousands of people were killed
Oppenheimer approaches them as almost as
if they are to be celebrated and gets
them to
reenact what they did because they're
proud they proud of they're proud of
these crimes and in the course of making
so he's making a movie within a movie
and in the course of following them
doing the that doing sort of these
reenact ments they start to get some
insight into what they did it's very
heavy but very very
powerful all right Lou nice
[Laughter]
segue no no come on if you're doing it
there we go I've put quite a lot on yeah
that's a little wild too much
possibly yeah there we
go cheers Lou what a ride we're in the
death zone this Summit let's get to the
summit see you on the other
side now yeah nothing fun about it but
the good news it looks you have a
contemplative look on your face you know
what I think just happened what I
attacked the shark
you I think I just killed the shark I
think you did too are you okay yes I'm
fine you need help buddy if you're okay
I'm okay that's all the strength
that's all the strength that I need and
the good news is Lou the wings of death
they're behind us thank you to close
things out yeah you know as an
occupation you've entered all of these
worlds some of them unseen some of them
outcasted some of them weird and bizarre
and then you've been doing it for so
long in this everchanging time what do
you see as the importance of empathy in
an increasingly fractured
world I love that question I'm getting
more heat now I might is there like
maybe I've got a time delay are you
getting more now yeah that's I I knew I
took what I did is I inhaled and so I
caught it all back a throat so then I
knew and then I know it grows and has
that time bomb thing so I knew I kind of
crashed right into the brick wall here
at the end but still have my feet I'm
fine so to take that step of reaching
out and attempting to see things uh I
think it's crucial I I honestly take the
approach in my
films and this is more by Instinct than
design that I assume a level of good
faith I assume that people out there for
the most part are doing the best they
can like very very few people get up in
the morning thinking how can I [__]
things up how can I be a bad person the
things that people do that do end up
being
destructive either it's just selfishness
which is you know very human or it's
idealism run a mck right it's this
feeling of being locked into a sense of
your own virtue that means that you are
you're failing to see the bigger picture
and you're kind of being programmatic
and and actually using people as
roadkill on your own journey of kind of
idealism does that make any kind of
sense like you think about atrocities
that are committed in the name of
Communism or fascism or ECOT terrorism
whatever it may be those are people
attempting to usher in a Golden Dawn
but nevertheless in many cases killing
hundreds or thousands or tens of
thousands or millions of people right um
so that's you know the empathy is sort
of um I think the Bedrock to to to to to
sort of preventing that and attempting
to not lose sight of the greater
Humanity I don't know I feel like I
maybe got a bit grandiose there for a
second but but that's you know that's
how I feel INF fueled by the wings Lou
taking them on yeah killing the shark
and living to tell the tale and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life uh
uh I have a series on BBC series of
interviews that is coming up depending
on when you're watching this I have
loads of I have 25 years of
documentaries that are out there I'm
really proud of my documentaries have
made 50 6070 on all kinds of subjects in
prisons in the adult industry about
religious groups Cults whatnot and uh I
think they're all pretty
good I agree with you I agree with
you that was nice man you had a good
time
yeah I'm glad we peaked with that one
and then the last two we were kind of
not coasting out of it but it felt um
like a story arc yeah yeah it felt like
okay here we are and actually um this is
this is dealable
with it was nice to see you suffering a
bit hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans with an announcement
truth or dab the game now has a brand
new refresh Edition that's right if you
already had the original truth or dab
game you can now get even more hotter
questions with the refresh Edition the
game is simple answer deeply personal
and potentially awkward questions or
face the Wrath of the last app that's
right both additions of the game feature
a mini bottle of the last dab hot sauce
check out the description below to see
where you can pick up hot ones truth or
dab the game or visit wildertools
[Music]